multi-faith worship has gathered at
Kuala Lumpur's Airport Buddhists Hindus
and Muslims prayed for the 239 people
who were on board the Malaysia Airlines
plane search teams continue to look for
traces of the loss plane 40 ships and 22
aircraft have been deployed by nearby
nations as well as the US so far they've
only found two large oil slicks there's
no proof they're linked to the missing
Boeing 777 the plane the same model as
the one seen here took off from Kuala
Lumpur shortly after midnight on
Saturday bound for Beijing around two
hours into the flight somewhere over the
sea between Malaysia and Vietnam it
disappeared from radar screens what
happened to the plane is still unclear
Malaysia's Air Force chief said it might
have changed course he looked back at
the recording and there is an imitation
possible indication that the aircraft
metal turn back and this is a you know
elaborate that at the moment we are as
we speak we are trying to make sense of
this authorities are investigating the
possibility of terrorism the passenger
list shows the names of two people whose
passports were reported stolen in
Thailand in recent years the two
passengers falsely using those passports
bought their tickets together we have
the CCTVs recording of those passengers
from from check in right to the
departure point and this this record of
the CCTVs have now been used at Beijing
Airport the destination flight mh370
never reached relatives and friends
continued to wait for news the airline
has told them to prepare for the worst